My name is Maria,
and I'm going to walk you through
on how I restored my Barbie's plane.
What makes this plane very special
is that they don't do
more of these planes anymore.
So it's an old plane that's 21 years old.
The plane was in really bad conditions.
The first thing I'm going to clean
is the inside of the plane.
The color of the plane
was originally blue,
but you can tell there's
some yellowish around
because it's too old.
The best way to clean the plane,
it will be doing circular motion
with the toothbrush.
That way, everything starts to come off.
And because I'm using the dish soap,
if there's something greasy on the plane,
it's going to take it off.
The biggest issue with
restoring this plane
are the stickers,
because you can barely
see what is on them.
For removing the stickers,
I'm going to use this red spatula
that is made of plastic silicone,
and very gently I'm going to go
through the windows
and all the parts that
have sticker residue.
It's extremely important
that we remove completely every residue.
If not, the primer will not stick well,
and we're going to see
painting of the primer breaking,
and then not even the sandpaper
is going to take that out.
So we have to be very,
very careful in this part.
After cleaning and
removing all the stickers,
it's very important to put this primer
before the spray paint,
because this is going to
let the other paint
just stick much better.
We don't want to spray a
lot of layers on the plane.
Otherwise it wouldn't
open well or track well.
We're just going to put two coats.
One, the primer, and then the spray paint.
The reason why I chose the spray paint
is because it sticks
very well on the plastic.
The spray technique,
it's pretty much just going from afar,
never close, and from left to right.
Very patient, so it doesn't drip.
The plane originally is made of plastic,
and it has no paint.
The plastic was originally blue.
So it was a challenge, because it's not
going to be 100% how it was before,
but it's going to be very, very close.
For the pink chairs,
I'm going to mix two
colors, white and red,
and then I'm going to
put it in an airbrusher
so I can spray them all around.
What is going to take me most of the time
is actually doing or
rebuilding the stickers.
I was trying to find
the stickers everywhere,
websites, internet, and
I couldn't find anything,
so that's why I decided
to do it by myself.
I had to print them in
two different papers.
The first, it's going to
be on a white background.
That was very useful
for the stickers that were on the windows,
the ones in the tail
that has the Barbie logo and everything.
And then for the flowers,
because the blue behind the flowers
was the original blue,
it was really hard to match
the spray paint that I used.
So I just went through a
transparent background,
so you can see the flowers
but you can also see through them
and see this beautiful new
blue from the spray paint.
To remember how or where
to put all these stickers
and not to miss anything,
I want to say I looked to the pictures
and I made my research,
but honestly I played
so much with this plane
that it was all in my mind
and I knew exactly which stickers
I had to make or where to put them.